hyundai nash traveler just released his
2022 hot list of where to stay eat and
visit for the first time it features
spots from around the world they include
a stunning resort in bermuda delicious
italian fair at mother wolf restaurant
in los angeles and nature trails and
coastal maine conde nast travelers
deputy global editorial director jesse
ashlock joins us right now good morning
how you doing jesse i'm doing great it's
great to be with you glad you're here so
you say this might be the hottest list
yet why so
all right three reasons that this year's
list is especially in fuego uh number
one reason is we're traveling
[Applause]
and it is now really and truly possible
to go to these places safely and smartly
um so the list the world's your oyster
the list is your oyster and um number
two reason is um hotels have not been
sitting on their hands during the
pandemic they have just come out with so
many great new properties and
experiences so there's so much out there
for you number three reason is because
all the additions of kanye's traveler
have come together to curate this list
for you and it's more than just just
hotels we've got trains we've got
cruises we've got cities so everything
you could want out of traffic let's go
down that list of trans cruising cities
but actually start with a hotel in
charleston sure a little one in south
carolina uh it's called the rider hotel
why is it special yeah the rider hotel
is a 50s building that's been rehabbed
as a kind of like cool slightly
miami-ish hipster spot one of a couple
hotels in charleston on the list this
year along with the lutrell charleston
is a terrific what we call an easy
escape like you can have a really really
luxurious and varied experience but
everybody can get to charleston easily
fun easy if you want a gentle re-entry
into travel i recommend that i recommend
charleston beach getaway nantucket i
hear it's about to be beach season and
uh nantucket is calling your name
there's a new spot called faraway
nantucket it's uh right in the town of
nantucket so easy access to the whaling
museum and all the great restaurants
there but it's like a you know
collection of uh cedar shingled
buildings like an old meeting house and
it's got like it's got a kind of like
away from town vibes especially when you
know the the breeze is coming in from
the sea it's called far away so that's a
great game for vacation
and speaking of far away the big sky
country montana is your recommendation
for people who want to take in nature i
will say i fully endorse that i as well
i was there in the fall and i love the
rugged grandeur of the west if you don't
want a beach you want the great expanses
um this is this is the place you want to
go to it's just uh north of yellowstone
national park um so in the summer time
you can have cycling in the beartooth
mountains you can have hiking you can
have the geysers and in the wintertime
it's a ski and ski out resort and big
sky has the largest amount of skiable
terrain in north america in the united
states what's the best hotel there best
hotel is big sky is montage big sky
it's the first real luxury entry into
the community and part of the
transformation of big sky um and uh it's
not you're kind of like antler chic it's
modern and contemporary and very very
stylish and i'm sure you can stream the
terrific paramount drama and big sky
streaming about yellowstone yes i'm sure
that's a popular choice
[Laughter]
well yeah i hear tony's a person who
wants to go on a cruise uh well i do
want to go to cruise my wife won't go so
what is the best crew actually what is
the most likely cruise to get katie chur
to agree to
well may i recommend the enchanted
princess the newest uh the newest ship
from princess um and it's part of their
medallion class of cruises so you can
wear this uh device on a lanyard or a
bracelet or whatever and everything is
touchless you know your uh your um
your gift shop your restaurants you can
order room service anywhere on the boat
from one of the four pools or eight hot
tubs or wherever you like um so that is
if you want an easy easy experience you
can't do better than that they're going
to canary islands later this month if
you want to you know suggest that to her
i don't know am i a canary island guy i
could be i could be
what about mexico you you describe it as
bussy
a lot of people are traveling there
whether it's couples young families even
singles it's like the new hot spot i'm
hearing tulum tulum tulum um is mexico a
good location and is it a forum
i love tulum tulum tulum but let's talk
about mexico city the capital the
biggest the biggest city in the country
um and mexico city was already really
having a moment before the pandemic hit
it's become a global like culinary and
art capital with like the museo samaya
and restaurants like pujol and then you
know like the work from everywhere uh
crowd came in during the pandemic and it
got even cooler and now there's um a
fabulous new ritz carlton tower that's
that's just opened that could be your
home base and a lot of new restaurants
in la candesa um and i think that mexico
city and mexico in general gives you
that kind of um
it's not too far away it's it's
accessible it's relatively affordable
but it feels like somewhere totally
different if you you know if you want a
new experience
trains
trains is this the year of the train i
think this year is the year of the train
also next year will be the year of the
train i think trains are back you know
if you see you see trains in the movies
all the time like wes anderson movie or
something you're like i want that irl
right and um well you can have it
belmonde has a new train in the uk
called the british pullman and
mr anderson actually uh designed one of
the carriages so you can ride in the
west anders experience to like the far
corners of the uk um there's also i feel
like the us is rather train starved and
um of course we're changing that because
uh there's this great um
new train called the rocky mountaineer
the glass
thank you so much